[Music]
hello everyone
i'm nick briscoe one of the instructors
here at the st louis chess club here for
openings explained and i am excited for
this one
that tonight we are going to be going
over the decline variation of the
nimsovich defense
uh probably the most popular response to
the nimzovich defense by those players
who know what they're doing
i will fully admit a couple weeks ago
before i was preparing this lecture
uh when i saw the nimzovich defense i
really was just like
all right i'm gonna take the center and
play principles
um but when i had to prepare this
lecture i realized there are much better
options for whites and we're gonna be
covering those tonight
so let's go to the board and the
nimzovich defense
comes after one e4 and two or sorry i
guess blacks move
one knight c6 uh we're going to talk
about this move
uh just this position for a little bit
here and kind of talk about
what is happening uh so here white has
played pawn to e4
claiming some space in the center
occupying with the pawn
and really just trying to take control i
i don't feel like i need to explain e4
more than that
but here with black's first move knight
to c6
you might see this a lot probably around
12 1400 level i see it a lot there
and here it looks like it's a good move
it looks like you're developing a piece
it looks like you're controlling the
sensor but this
actually is not the case if white wanted
to
they can just play pawn to d4 anyways
and
this can be kind of what black hopes for
playing d4
is very principled you know if your
opponent gives you the center take it
but i want to talk about why this may
cause a problem
and i believe the move here is actually
e5 and
after e5 black is telling white
you need to make a decision how are you
going to handle the center here
and there are a couple options some good
some not so good
but white can choose to take they can
choose to push they can try and defend
with pawn to c3
but no matter what option white takes
they're going to have to commit their
central structure
which gives black a solid plan for what
to do next
um so while those positions can be good
here tonight i'm going to be
recommending the move knight to f3
and this is the declined variation of
the nimesovic defense
here we are just uh adding some
reinforcements to the squares that black
has decided they want to take control of
and here funny enough the best move is
probably
not e6 whoops the best move here is
probably
just playing pawn to e5 and transposed
to a normal king's pawn opening
where white has the option to play
bishop b5 bishop c4
pawn to d4 more of your standard
classical chess
so for the sake of tonight's lecture
we're not going to look at pawn to e5
we're going to be looking at the
other options that black has because we
are after all looking at the nimzovich
defense
we're not going to be looking at any of
the king's knight openings
um i do want to mention that this
opening does have a lot of
transpositions in it so if you're
looking as black
to i guess get some position you want in
a different move order try and psych out
your opponents
this might be a defense to look at and
for the white player
you really do want to know a lot of your
lines because this can transpose to many
different openings
you have something that resembles the
scandinavian you have
a line in the tarash french you have
lines like the piers
or at least lines that resemble those
structures
so you do want to make sure you're
familiar with those
but let's get right into it i think
first we're going to start off
with pawn to d5
and after pawn to d5 this is where we
get
kind of a transposition to a
scandinavian
i don't believe it's a true scandinavian
but the structures are the same
so white should handle it uh very
similarly
they take on d5 and now black takes with
the queen
and what do you do in the scandinavian
here you just play knight to c3
getting a tempo off of the queen if
you're black the queen must move
otherwise you're just going to lose a
queen and again just like the
scandinavian the most popular move here
is queen to a5 after queen to a5 the
queen just moves to the edge of the
board
tries to get to some safety now one of
the main differences
between here in the nimsovich defense
and the
scandinavian is that your knight on c6
blocks your pawn on c7
so you can no longer play pawn to c6
creating an
uh i guess an escape route for your
queen
this can lead to some problems if black
isn't careful their queen can get
trapped
normally in this position white will
play bishop to b5
pinning the knight on c6 black is just
simply going to break the pin
white castles and now black will play
pawn to a6
hitting the bishop they want to get this
bishop out of their
maybe castle side but try and give white
problems along the way
so here what should white do with this
bishop
some people may think dropping back to
a4 is fine
after all it is protected by the knight
some may say go back to
c4 and hit the potentially weak f7
square
but i'm going to recommend taking on c6
nick why are you doing this you're
giving away the bishop pair well
it's going to come down to development
overall after bishop retakes
you get pawn to d4 you again have this
center
and two knights can arguably be more
developed
than a queen and bishop and if you
really want the
determining factor white is castled here
so white is up in development
moves like knight e5 will come in the
future black does have
two options here that have been played
in actual games
the first option is castle's long
so we have knight to e5 hitting the
bishop and the f7 pawn the bishop drops
to e8 to protect it now bishop to e3
solidifying your center
there is pressure from the rook and here
is really hard to find the best move
for black computer best move is knight
h6
but what has been played in actual games
is pawn to f6
i believe in the mco uh 15th edition
they marked that the knight should go to
d3
and if the knight goes to d3 this
position is equal
it is balanced but uh i'm going to give
the chat a couple seconds here to see if
they can find the best move
one that can lead to a very strong
advantage possibly even winning
so we'll give give white uh
i guess give the chat moves to find time
to find a move for white
can't talk tonight
jonathan bernhard queen f3 x clam
okay i like the idea i like the idea
so queen to f3 and probably hitting upon
an idea that's going to pop up
very shortly so after queen to f3
the idea is that uh if black takes
you can take on f8 and then most of
black's pieces are pinned you're
threatening to take
on g8 and black's gonna have a really
hard time developing here
however e takes d4 you can't really
take back it's not going to be as fun i
guess you can take with the bishop here
but bishop c6 your queen's starting to
get hit if you take on g7
knight to f6 should be winning for black
because the rooks are going to come to
g8 and then
the rook is going to threaten to take on
g2 so
this can be a pretty interesting
position i guess the queen can come to
f4 if you want to be safe but
this position is probably going to be
equal because black is able to develop
the bishop
so we'll go back to
what is it here when the queen is still
on d1 after f6
we have pietro and a couple other people
saying knight to c4
knight to c4 also can be equal
probably favors black a little bit more
after queen to h5
just the queen is safe here offering a
trade
white can decline the trade with queen
to e1
but now black can kind of break in the
center with e5 and get
more play than we want to give them so
again we'll go back
see if anyone can find the absolute best
move
all right we see pawn to f4
i'm not really sure what the idea is
with pawn to f4 because after the pawn
takes
and you take back with the f pawn you
can go knight h6
and the bishop is defended by the rook
so no discovery here
pawn to f4 is just losing for white
back to the idea of queen f3 this
definitely was a little bit chaotic
but black out a little bit of play here
and that is mainly because in the line
that we went over
uh when you take after bishop to c6 this
rook on d8 is protected by the king
so in order to get the most we can out
of this position
we're actually going to go queen to g4
checking
first and the idea is that after the
king goes to b8
now we have queen f3 and then if they
take
we take on f8 and now the position is
winning for white
because this rook is not defended
anymore with this rook
undefended all the pieces really are
pinned there is no bishop to c6 because
of queen d8
check so queen to g4
is really going to hurt black
so with that position being shown black
does not want to take on e5
so the best move for them here is
probably e6
but after e6 we have pawn pawned a3 and
now you're threatening moves like
pawn to b4 just attacking the queen
and white is just gonna have a overall
better position because of their space
and because they're able to tempo the
queen a lot
so let's see the move here knight h6
pawn to b4
queen to b6 and now here there's the
move
d5 a discovery on the queen i think you
guys are getting the idea here this
queen
it just cannot find a safe square queen
to d6
knight to c4 attacking it again
queen to d7 and rook f2d1 will
finish white's development where black
still has
four pieces on the back row this knight
is on the edge of the board
black is not having a great time here
okay so that's going to be the main idea
of this
scandinavian line in the nimsovich can't
really find anything much
better the only other alternative here
that's worth the try is instead of
castles queen side
they play e6 which you know they don't
have to castle queenside now they can
try to do their best to develop their
pieces and castle kingside
here white will not get this crazy
advantage that they had in the other
line where they castled first
here's going to be a bit more equal
white is going to have a slight
advantage they're going to be better
but this is actually worth a try for
black you'll see that
they give up a little bit of integrity
in their queenside pawn structure
but they're going to have a safer king
overall and
actually be able to develop their pieces
and just illustrative moves here
um nothing too crazy when the queen goes
to f3 it's hitting the c6 pawn so the
knight has to go to e7
instead of f6 knight to e4
is just centralizing the knight getting
on the bishop
black offers a queen trade and really
the only thing for white to watch out
for here is make sure they don't trade
the queens
if they trade the queens then it's going
to go into an end game which doesn't
necessarily favor whites yes black
black has these doubled c pawns um but
they don't have a light square bishop to
get the c6 pawn
and their dark square bishop is
contested by black's dark square bishop
okay back to move two so that was our
first
kind of transposition into kind of a
scandinavian it's a worse scandinavian
for black so i do not recommend
that black plays this looking first
candy
one of the other moves here probably one
of the other big transpositions
is e6 and i faced this in a game just
last week on
chess.com and this was like the only
line i didn't prep
so i figured i had to include it tonight
so pawn e6 and this is going to
transpose into a french defense
specifically grimard's line in the
terrace variation
now me i'm a classical french guy i
don't play any terrash stuff
so this game was very foreign to me
the idea is here here you do go
d4 because black has already played e6
they can't you know if they go e5 they
just kind of burn a tempo
and now after pawn to d5 like the best
square for the knight is like back to b8
um it's not going to be great for black
undeveloping like this
so white can get away with d4 and black
should go
pawn to d5
here there are a few different ideas but
the most played move is knight b to d2
and here you're gonna see um the knight
goes to d2
that way the pawn can go to c3 and
protect d4
and then bishop might come to d3 might
go to b5
could just go to e2 and then white is
going to castle king's side
um but here's the main line here after
knight f6
pawn to e5 knight d7 standard maneuver
in this dinos variation
if they try and go knight to e4
then white just goes c3 and they have a
better position
almost plus two the one
thing that white should not do is take
on e4
this can be terrible because after the
pawn takes
this knight has to move best swears g5
but this pawn on d4 is going to fall
after queen takes
and after the queen trade there's no
guarantee this position is good for
white
black is about black is about plus one
and a half here
so as long as white just remembers
protect on d4 with c3
don't trade on e4 2 early they should be
fine
and now here we go into probably the
best move
right away is pawn to d6 if your
opponent is playing the nimzovich
defense and they're not wanting a
transposition
this is going to be the main move they
play they play
pawn to d6 and this is the williams
variation
i guess someone was asking in the
terrace variation
after c3 what if they go f6
give me a moment i will pull that line
back up
to do there e6
we go through after c3
pawn to f6 you can probably just take
and
i'm not sure you know what way black is
going to take back
makes sense to go with the knight queen
looks like it may also be okay but i
mean you could just take it
no matter what way black takes back
bishop can go to d3 and you're going to
castle kingside
and you'll have have a fine position
stockfish 13 is giving this an
evaluation of plus 1.6 for white
so i guess the line you're wanting is
knight takes f6
like i said just bishop d3 still don't
know what black is doing
they can try bishop d6 try and develop
and castle
both sides get castle and then
rook e1 this knight can go to f3 and g3
or e3 this bishop can get out to g5
pin the knight i mean there's there's
just easy development for white many
options
and here the i guess one of the reasons
why this is a worse french is with the
knight on c6
you don't get this c5 break that you get
in most french's
so hopefully that should answer dm's
question now back to d6 like i said this
is going to be the main stuff
and here after pawn to d6
um we're going to go pawn to d4 again
black has now announced you know okay
i'm not going to just
strike right away and force you to
commit
black has already committed to either
d6 e6 or d6 e5
which we'll actually look into right now
after pawn to e5
after pawn to e5 this is a transposition
into the philidor defense
so i have a friend who's a expert who
plays this transposition
a lot um trying to catch
catch e4 players off guard
white has nothing to fear they can just
go into a slightly better end game
after d takes and now the main move is
knight takes
if pawn takes this is a bit dubious
um black or sorry white can just trade
queens and the king should take
if the knight takes you're just
undeveloping you're hanging this pawn in
the center
so so the king really does need to take
here and then
white can just play bishop c4 and just
enjoy that first move advantage
in the end game
so after pawn takes if knight takes
just trade the knights again go into
this end game where you might be
slightly better
because you have this first move
advantage that's that's what white's
going to be counting on
in this line so that was the
little transposition to the philidor if
they don't want to transpose to a
philidor
then you're probably going to see knight
2f6
all right uh knight two f6 here i guess
someone was saying
pawn d5 in some line was okay
um but i don't know what move that they
are suggesting it
so i'm going to keep going through this
main line knight to f6
and this position is going to resemble a
pierce
a pierce defense because they have the
pawn on d6
the knight is on f6 one idea you might
see is pawn to g6 and a fiance like a
regular pierce
but this knight is on c6 where normally
in the pier
you'll see the knight go to a6 pawn
probably playing to
c5 and that knight is going to reroute
in the future
uh let's see that d5 comment earlier was
saying as
three e5 uh yes yes advancing the pawn
should also be fine
um but i think uh most tried and tested
at least at the top level is going to be
trading going into that end game
okay after knight f6 there's a couple
things that white
needs to think about mainly this knight
attacking this
hanging pawn on e4 what is the best way
for white to defend this do they go
knight to c3 do they go knight d2 do
they go bishop d3
can they try and get away with pushing
do they go queen e2 the other knight to
d2
i mean what is the best move obviously
not all those moves are good
but the best move here is probably going
to be knight to c3
another good try is bishop to d3
just developing the bishop getting ready
to castle right away
but knight c3 is the move that i've
chosen to cover tonight
where the most common response from
black is bishop to g4
and the idea behind this move is uh very
simple
just pin the knight you're going to try
and uh
take d4 so if white just tries to play
pawn to h3
then bishop h3 and if they mess up and
play queen takes f3
they just hang their center pawn so
there is a little trick here
but one that white shouldn't have to
worry about too much
all white needs to do to counter this is
develop their other bishop to e3 just
reinforce d4
over protect your center and you will be
fine
bishop e2 is also a good idea that was
suggested by imani in the chat here
after bishop to e2 though what i don't
like is that this bishop on e2
is a little passive there is no
guarantee that black is going to take on
f3
so you know even after if they take and
take
your bishop is going to be looking kind
of like a tall pawn this diagonal
is probably not the best i would much
rather try and develop the bishop
somewhere where it can have more
influence over the game
probably c4 looking at f7 again
you can go to d3 and then after an
eventual e5 it will have this long
diagonal to work with
you know bishop e2 not blundering white
still
is going to have that first move
advantage but i do prefer bishop to e3
just because we don't know the best
square for this light square bishop yet
and here we reach a position where black
has a couple different options here
first we'll cover probably i don't want
to say worst because that really makes
it sound bad but
g6 seems natural
where after g6 you know normal peers
player might think this position is fine
but already white can give some serious
pressure
you have pawn to h3 hitting the bishop
and now after this pawn has been played
to g6 they cannot retreat to h5
because if they go back to h5 pawn to g4
traps the bishop
and white is going to win a piece
so that leaves black with really only
one option they have to take on f3
if black plays some other move like
after h3 and they go back to d7
you know this could be a way to play but
why why is black putting their bishop on
g4
if uh you know they're going to go back
to d7 ideally black would have prepped
this before they play it and they would
see that
if they try and go g6 white does have h3
going back to d7 is just too passive
really allows white to open up the
center with e5
and then just the piece development is
better white will have a
much more comfortable position here
computer says they're winning
i think it's too early in the game to
practically say white's going to win
every time
but white will have a better game
so yeah they had to take on f3 now the
queen is able to take on f3 because
you over protected your center so there
is no more knight takes d4
black can continue with natural
development bishop to g7 looking to
castle
but here white castle's queen side and
this is a very common idea you will see
um where if one side's trying to castle
the side which is
develops is going to castle on the
opposite side so they can throw all
their pawns towards
the enemy king this idea is very common
in like the yugoslav dragon
so and pretty much any opening where
there's this fiancato structure
launching your pawns specifically h4h5
is normally a strong idea
we'll see black castle pawn to g4
pawn to e5 trying to get in the center
but black has waited just too long to
play this
they can just take on e5 note that the
pawn cannot take back because it will
hang the queen
so they have to take with the knight
after the knight takes back
white just moves the queen out of the
danger
black makes a move like rookie 8 and now
white gets pawn to f4 and these pawns
on the king side are just going to come
way faster
than any possible advance black is going
to have
black has really just waited too long to
get into this game and why he's going to
steamroll on the king's side
is he like knight e to d7 is he pawn to
e5
just breaking a temporary pawn sacrifice
this is really just to block the rook
from having
any influence on the game because this
bishop can hang in some lines
but now you'll see pawn to f5 and this
pawn on e5 is just blocking the rook
kind of makes the rook f to e8 look a
little silly
queen to e7 g5 hitting the knight the
knight moves
and here after pawn f6 white is already
getting a material advantage
and this was played in the game rizzo
done
back in 2011. where after knight takes
here white's already up a piece but i'll
show the end of this game
just to show how quickly it can end
bishop c4 hitting f7
a rook might come to f1 adding pressure
to the f file
so knight f4 blocking it off queen e4
getting to safety
pawn to c6 just trying to save these
pawns but after rook
d7 you know white is going to be ready
to take on f7
after rook to f8 defending it now
there's bishop to c5 hitting the rook
and if the rook doesn't move
then you'll see how it ends here is
bishop to e7 and black resigns because
the queen is actually
being trapped here
so g6 probably not the way to go
let's see what is another try for black
i think the most popular here
is pawn to e6 adopting a small center
approach
black has already developed the bishop
outside of the chain
so now they're able to play e6 kind of
getting
prepared for either pawn break white may
have
here the main line is pawn to h3 hitting
the bishop
and now here the bishop can go to h5
because this pawn was not played to g6
so after bishop to h5
now white has a decision to make do they
play d5 do they play e5
and probably the best move here is d5
you have this bishop on the dark squares
it's not really looking at too much here
but you want to maximize its potential
covering the entire board so you play d5
clearing out this bishop
this bishop is ready to come to the
queen side in the future
after pawn takes pawn takes and here we
see inner meso
from black they take on f3 first and
this is just to gain time
because after queen recaptures there's
knight e5 hitting the queen again
so that is the point of bishop takes f3
the queen can just drop back to e2
you might question why it's blocking the
bishop here
but white is going to play g4 probably
bring the bishop to g2
where it can help support this d5 pawn
we see pawn to a6 and the reason for
this is that if this rook moves at all
we don't want the bishop to snipe that
pawn
white will castle queen side bishop to
e7 developing pawn to f4
tempo on the knight so the knight has to
move and then
pawn to g4 and white has a better
position here due to the space advantage
and this position was reached in galubev
versus markowski white ended up winning
that game
uh bl 1995.
so e6 um again nice try
small center but still a little too
passive
okay i'm annie's asking about
f4 where
where in the game for f4
probably f4 after a6
just a note to the viewers in the chat
it helps a lot more if you put a move
number next to your suggestions
but i'm going to assume that iron man is
asking about why not
f4 after a6 and the main idea you know
f4 is still great f4 is still a winning
move
just hitting the knight the knight can
move
but you really want to start you know
making sure your own king is safe
all of your pieces are developed before
you start launching an attack
it would be a little awkward to go for
this attack
and then have to be like okay i've
attacked you but i need to make sure i'm
safe and then i'm going to go back to
attacking you
there's a more i guess there's a better
flow if you have a
continuous plan of i'm going to you know
make sure i'm safe and then go for the
attack
okay that covers e6 again probably a
little too passive
and then we're going to get into what i
believe is the best
practical try for black if you're trying
to play
the nimzovich defense this is probably
going to be what you're going for
in a game e5 not the most popular move
but it's probably the best practical try
again
okay what does white do here after pawn
to e5
that is the question that black is
asking they are contesting the center
they're not leaving it up to white to
decide what pawn break they're going to
get
black is saying hey i'm i'm getting the
center here
i'm gonna trade if you let me um try and
get my bishop and castle i'm in this
game too
uh there's a couple moves here for white
but there's two two big ones that i want
to talk about
um ellie moosa in the chat
is suggesting pawn to d5 and this is one
of the two
major options white can play
pawn to d5 just hitting the knight right
away
and this is fine but i believe that this
position is going to
not give white everything they can have
going to lead to more of an equal
position
and i will show the line from min
hazuden versus ide
it was white ended up winning this game
in
county manchester of 2010
but the position that we get is actually
equal and white ended up winning i
believe because
of just a big elo gap
the other move is bishop to b5 and i
will be covering that
after this d5 line i'm annie so i'm
annie suggested bishop to b5
that is the other move after pawn to d5
the knight just goes to e7
it has to move out of danger it's
looking to come to g6 and possibly hop
on f4
pawn to h3 will just get a tempo off the
bishop right away the bishop goes back
to d7
here black doesn't have to take
because there is no pressure on d4
anymore it's not like black is going to
get anything out of it
probably is better just to save the
bishop keep it on the board use it to
build complications later
and most likely help with the c6 break
we see bishop to e2 knight to g6
again looking to come to f4
and here pawn to g3 just
stopping this knight from coming to f4
h4
you see bishop to e7 black is trying to
castle now
and pawn to h4 the reason we have this
move is
if white is wanting to castle king side
they cannot leave their h
pawn hanging this bishop is on d7 it is
eyeing the pawn so they have to move it
out of the way
pawn to h6 just
i guess creating a square for this
knight to reroute itself in the future
but honestly this move is a little
unclear to me
and pawn h5 the knight goes to f8 there
is no other square for it to go to
knight to h4 looking to come to f5
maybe there's tactics in the future on
g6 but that's going to be way down the
line
um and then we see pawn two c6 so this
is the break that black is going to try
and go for
try and break up white center and this
is kind of an idea that you'll see
in the french so we actually earlier
talked about
black playing f6 in that terrace
transposition line
where white can just take here white
doesn't take
they just develop they play like knight
f5
and queen c8 trying to take on f5 and
win a pawn
so white just defends with g4 they do
not want to take on e7
this is still going to be good but the
idea of not taking on e7
is just because this knight is really
hurting black's position really cramping
it
and after g4 you just retain a space
advantage
this bishop on e7 is doing nothing
really
uh bishop takes e pawn takes
knight to h7 can come to g5
queen to d2 pawn to c5 f4
after takes if bishop takes you're
hitting d6 adding pressure
someone's asking why not take the pawn
on g7
so after taking on g7 it looks like
actually all this is winning i believe
what happened is
white may have missed an opportunity in
this game
looks like they played g4 but yes taking
on g7
is the best move why why they didn't
play this i'm not entirely sure
i'm not one of the masters who played
this game
but let's see back to our position
bishop to b5 pinning trading again
hitting d6
and this position is equal so with that
comment
uh let me see what is
going on with black here so queen c8
is the problem maybe white just missed
it
it looks like if they want to keep
equality bishop takes f5
ef5 and then cd5
and there's a check that white can give
black blocks it with the knight
but this position is actually reading as
very slightly
better for black so i think this is
actually an error on my part i think i
overlooked this
and this is why i'm glad we have the
live chat fix these errors
as they happen don't have to respond to
those nasty youtube comments in the
future
but yes it looks like g4
is uh or the queen c8 rather is the
blunder
they do need to take on f5 so that is a
good way for
for black to kind of get a little bit of
an edge against this d5 line
okay um let's see
and it looks like the last big line
is after e5 so we just went over d5
um chat caught my mistake with queen c8
and black does have an equal position
after bishop f5
i think the best move here is going to
be bishop to b5
after bishop to b5 you're pinning the
knight immediately threatening to play
d5
and try and win a piece
so we see knight to d7 breaking this pin
it doesn't really make much sense for
the bishop to go to d7
you're kind of just undeveloping and
black is giving up this pin that they
had
where this knight is putting pressure on
e5
so actually white could exploit this
right away by taking on c6 if bishop
takes
it looks like queen to d3 to protect the
pawn first
but uh now after you know trading in the
center
white has more development you know two
knights and a bishop and a queen versus
a bishop and a knight
and white is ready to castle white just
has a nice time advantage here
so knight to d7 and here pawn to d5
right away
knight has to move best square is to
undevelop
set up for the next game and now pawn to
h3
so in a lot of these lines with this pin
on g4 you'll see white
playing h3 this is something that
they're trying to
take care of
bishop to h5 maintaining the pin
and now pawn to g4 you'll see white
gaining space
on the king side here bishop has to go
to g6 don't want to hang a bishop
and now pawn to h4 pawn h5 to stop
advancing and here i'm actually going to
take a pause and ask the chat what to
play in this position because there
are a lot of options for white some may
be
good some may be great some may be not
so good
so i want to see what the chat has here
as ideas
we'll cover those one by one
looks like the chat is going on some
adventure
talking about the sicilian
unfortunately there are no sicilian
transpositions with the knight on c6
okay uh our first suggestion
is g5 and i really like this
this is the move that i recommend in
this position
pawn to g5 now what is the point with
pawn to g5
um while you're trying to type the point
of pawn to g5 i will cover the other
move that was suggested
knight to g5 so knight to g5
this also looks pretty good trying to
get into black's position but there's
really no
no targets that you're hitting here yes
f7 is weak
i guess in the long term with the king
being one of the defenders but with the
bishop on g6 and no way to kick the
bishop
i find it very hard to justify this
knight going to g5 though it's not a big
problem
someone is suggesting bishop to g5
i do not like this move as much after
bishop to g5
black just blocks with the bishop bishop
to e7
and then after white takes black takes
back
there's not much development left for
black to do they just need to get this
knight off of b8
maybe they castle maybe they don't let's
say you played
g5 here to stop them from taking on g4
well now black has pawn to c6
if you try taking then the pawn is going
to take back you have to move your
bishop
and now black has a better pawn center
so don't really want to take so you move
your bishop back
and then here um allows black to go
knight b6 and the other knight is going
to come to d7
and this is pretty equal position um
it looks like uh stockfish 13 saying
slightly better for black
but nothing too crazy it's all all under
uh minus one half
so not a big fan of bishop to g5 i don't
think that
white with this space advantage should
be looking to trade off pieces
and that's another general rule in chess
so for those of you who don't know
if one side has a space advantage you
don't want to trade off pieces
if you're the side who's cramped you do
want to trade off pieces
the reason for this is because if you
know you're cramped you don't have a lot
of squares for your pieces
well the less pieces you have then the
less squares you need
so looks like there's no other
big suggestions so we'll look at g5
which again is the move i recommend
and the main point i see some people
saying that
pawn to g5 looks spicy
i do not agree this is probably the
opposite of spicy
is you're actually locking up the
position to make sure you retain this
space advantage on the king side and in
the center
and you can go like queen d2 or queen d3
and castle long
again with these other moves like knight
g5 knight g5 was a good try
i will give credit there because then
the bishop does protect the pawn
um you do not want to trade pawns here
because after bishop takes h5
you have this pin again and it's again
just annoying you have to go bishop
to e2 this is undeveloping your piece
something you want to try and avoid in
the openings
no it wasn't a typo
it wasn't spicy they were saying spacey
got it
got it wasn't a typo so yes g5
spacey i'll take it i'll take it just
keeping the space locking it up
and then the way that this went in this
game
this game was a pavasovic versus
mesotropic
in 2002 and it went
bishop e7 knight to d2
pawn to c6 bishop to e2 you have to
retreat your attacked piece
knight to b6 again we're seeing this
idea where knight to b6 the other knight
can come in
knight to f1 is just a maneuver by white
maybe go to g3 and f5 it's an idea
but actually white has different plans
in this game
so after cd5 the bishop takes on b6 and
the reason
for this is you're actually clearing out
the e3 square
for your knight so after pawn takes back
um you know knight e3 is possible but
you are
you know you do need to take back this
pawn and
uh i guess the last question i have for
the chat here is what way does white
take back this pawn
it does have some significance on the
position you have three options you have
pawn takes knight takes and queen takes
so this is an open question to the
audience which recapture
is the best
there's another move which isn't
recapturing which
is good bishop to b5 um
which after they block then you can
recapture um
let's see what what are the suggestions
okay we have jonathan
bernhard saying queen takes we have
garrett saying the knight takes and then
changing their mind to queen takes
and philippe is saying definitely not
the pawn
okay so let's go through it one by one
we'll start with the pawn and why one
might say
definitely don't recapture with the pawn
after retaking with the pawn this does
open up
the light square bishop kind of makes me
a little
depressed that black is getting this
much play um
just because you know you don't want to
help your opponent if you can help it
so don't take with the pawn you don't
want to just
let this diagonal open for your opponent
you can go knight takes but if you try
knight takes
bishop to e4 and then i'm not sure what
white does here
probably just bishop f3 over protecting
protecting this attack on the rook
offering a trade
but this trade after bishop to d5 and
queen d5
knight to c6 protecting against the
queen b7 threat
this position is a bit more equal white
has this slight advantage but nothing to
write home about
so that leaves us with the third option
and by process of elimination
we can almost say you can play queen
takes without calculating but we should
um if we want to make sure we're making
good moves here
queen to d5 and what is the point the
main idea
is you leave this pawn on e4 this dark
bishop
is left on a closed diagonal i want to
make sure that
black isn't getting any play these
pieces on the
dark square diagonal here those are shot
out of play
black canned castle but the rook has no
easy way to get to an open file
this rook is only staring at the a2 pawn
which is defended
um but here in the actual game that was
played
white took with the e pawn and then
ended up grinding and end game
but if you take with the queen you're
gonna have a much easier time because
black won't have more counter play
so those are all of my those are all my
main suggestions
for the nimesovic defense we will leave
the last bit of this time
for any questions over any of the
variations
so again if you're suggesting a move
please add move numbers makes it
much easier to tell what you're talking
about
and yeah questions
jonathan just has this comment that d6
will remain
weak and castles becomes an alternative
this is true this bishop on e7 does
protect the the d6 pawn so it may not be
as weak as you claim
but yes definitely with the queen on d5
and after castles long with the rook on
d1
d6 is definitely a target and you have
moves like knight to b5
which can help put pressure and black
may be forced to give up this center
pawn
did we cover the nimesovic scandinavian
variation we did
we did we covered that in the very
beginning where after
uh knight f3 they go d5
any other questions
are there any lines that we need to go
over again
see making sure i didn't miss anything
in my notes
i think that's it so if we don't have
any questions
we'll end this lecture a little early i
want to thank everyone for coming in
checking this out tonight really good
interaction
yeah i just want to thank everybody with
me being the new instructor for chess
openings explained
you know if you do have openings you
want to see covered feel free to drop
them in the comments section below
i'm always taking a look getting your
guys suggestions
and who knows if you ask early enough
you might get it featured
so again thanks everybody i'll see you
next week
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital
and preeminent global destination for
lovers of the sport
we look forward to seeing you in our new
space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships 2021 u.s juniors and
senior championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
you